[Musique]
même si les petits le grain de riz est
la principale denrée alimentaire de près
de la moitié de la population mondiale
dans la kfw de frapper en mars l'année
dernière nous ça explose et on a
travaillé dès 12 heures par jour parce
que les gens jetant du riz puis canal à
l'épicerie les tablettes de riz était
vide on a vu un marché augmenter de 20%
l'an dernier il existe deux grandes
familles de riz lait riz à grains long
et leary agrès moyens et courts leyrit à
grains longs sont ceux que nous
connaissons depuis toujours on en trouve
de multiples variétés dans les reee
moyens et courts les plus connus sont
les risottos et les riz à sushi qu'on
reconnaît à leurs formes arrondies
probablement des plus beaux du monde
le riz a fait voyager richard de palmas
sur trois cantines à un riz blanc est un
ricky à auquel on a par friction enlever
sa pellicule leçons et qui fait passer
du statut de brand complet à blanc sans
cette pellicule le riz blanc cuit plus
vite que le bras si le riz brun et plus
nutritif que le blanc il est aussi plus
amère et difficile à digérer pour
certains depuis les années 1910 on
utilise un procédé qui transfère une
partie de la valeur nutritive du riz
brun horrible c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'étuvage
du et à toro va est importatrice de riz
chez agro fusion ici on en sache du riz
provenant du monde entier dont le riz
étuvé des états unis appelé aussi
conditionné convertis ou colruyt de
l'erié va être trempé est ensuite mis
sous vapeur ce qui va faire que le son
une partie du son et du germe vos comms
être infuser dans le grain et ça va
produire une gélatine isation doute
pourquoi le riz étuvé et plus doré le
riz étuvé est beaucoup plus santé que le
riz blanc vu que avec ce procédé
d'étuvage absorber une partie des
éléments nutritifs du riz bras mais ce
qui fait que le riz étuvé est très
populaire
c'est qu'ils ne collent pas deux autres
ils ont le jasmin de thaïlande et le
basmati de l'inde ou du pakistan
caunes est fort engouement est le boss
m'a titre se reconnaît très facilement
c'est un grand qui est très très fort à
la cuisson il va avoir énormément de
deux parfums et un parfum sur des notes
un petit peu terre
comparativement à 1 au tri qui va être
ici le riz jasmin qui aussi harry
parfumé qu'un gars aussi long d'un tout
petit peu plus large et qui lui à la
cuisse on va dégager des parfums très
floraux d'où le nom la différence
fondamentale entre ces deux ris parfumée
c'est leur texture collante le ribadou
basmati va avoir tendance à être
beaucoup plus loose moins collant que le
riz jasmin qui valent et recherché pour
ce pour ce côté collants on trouve aussi
beaucoup de riz instantané
un aliment transformé pour gagner du
temps ça c'est du riz instantané
on le voit tout de suite parce que le
rire comme été brisées justement pour
qu'ils puissent absorber l'eau plus
rapidement lorsqu'ils vont être cuit le
grès gonflé rice krispies il est pré
cuits jeu et blanchissent le grain de
riz blanc et ensuite ils vont le mettre
sous vapeur et le sécher ce qui va faire
qui va craquer comme ça on peut le cuir
beaucoup plus rapidement après sachant
que la plupart des récuse en 10 à 15
minutes
l'argument vitesse du riz instantané ne
tient pas la route
surtout qu'on obtient au final un
produit vidée de la plupart de ces
nutriments une des variétés parmi les
plus populaires l'an dernier et un riz
cultivé en californie le cal rose dont
les ventes ont été sans doute stimuler
par l'engouement pour les poké et sari
qui est facilement reconnaissable parce
qu'il est il est courant formenty poiron
dit il fait partie de la catégorie des
hri agréé moyens et courts
tout comme le riz bamba pour la paella
et les riz arborio et carnaroli utilisé
en risotto série sont plus collant car
ils contiennent plus d'amis dans
l'art borio est assez reconnaissable
parce qu'il est souvent opaque à tous
ceux ci s'ajoutent des rides couleurs
ici on a le fameux raspberry les
rivières de boue violet le raspberry est
un croisement entre henri entier et un
reee jasmin violet noir ou rouge série
demande une cuisson plus longue
tout comme le riz sauvage qui n'est pas
un vie à proprement parler mais plutôt
une graminée originaire d'amérique du
nord
c'est toujours bien d'avoir un sac
transparent comme ça cela n'enleve alors
le projet puis on peut le voir voir le
riz nous permettent d'examiner les
grains de riz pour observer s'ils sont
entiers et s'ils sont exempts de
poussière on peut aussi constater la
composition des mélanges et méfiez vous
des affirmations et du marketing puisque
en dehors du biologique
rien n'est vérifié et tout peut être dit
quand c'est marqué basmati complet
basmati pur basmati premium
ces appellations le sont pas sont pas
contrôlés le consommateur va avoir plus
de difficultés du coup à se retrouver en
face des différentes dénominations parce
que entre guillemets tout est permis
cotée en bourse le prix du riz fluctue
au gré de l'offre de la demande et des
facteurs climatiques le riz blanc long
et les visites uv se vendent autour de
deux dollars 20 le kilo le riz
instantané plus du double à 5 $ le kilo
les basmati jasmin et riz à sushi
avoisine le 6 dollars 2 kg et compté
jusqu'à 30 % de plus pour des versions
bio acheter le riz en plus grosse
quantité ça se conserve un à certains
disent deux ans même trois ans si vous
ne mettez dans un contenant hermétique
dans un endroit frais et sec qui a pas
de problème comme ça vous sauver des
coûts puis c'est plus écologique et
moins d'emballage à l'exception des
riverains et sauvage la contribution du
riz en termes de fibres et de protéines
est plutôt limité c'est néanmoins une
céréale qui fournit une bonne quantité
d'énergie sous forme de glucides
complexes et qui accompagne à merveille
quantité de plants